Hello again movie fans.
We're back with another challenging quiz for
you to test your cinematic knowledge on.
If you think you know everything there is
to know about the weird and wonderful world
of movies, then you're going to love this!
Coming up are ten questions about some of
the biggest movies around - both old and new
- and if you can get all of them right, then
you can truly consider yourself to be a serious
movie buff!
Keep your score as you go along and then leave
it in the comment section below!
Make sure you tell the truth though, as we're
always watching!This is the latest edition
of Screen Rant's Ultimate Movie Quiz.
Back to the Future
The brilliant Back to the Future featured,
amongst other things, a dog called Einstein,
a time-travelling De-Lorean and a padded,
burnt orange down vest, but which related
real-life figure did writers Robert Zemeckis
and Bob Gale receive a letter from after he
saw the movie?
A - Bernhard Caesar Einstein, Grandson of
Albert Einstein
B - John DeLorean, Founder of DeLorean Motor
Company
C - Eddie Bauer, Inventor of the Down Vest
(Screen lights up B)
The writers of Back to the Future actually
received a fan letter from John DeLorean - the
man whose company made the DeLorean car that
was featured in the movie - after it was released,
thanking them for immortalising his car.
Titanic
The production of the 1997 epic Titanic involved
creating a lifesized model of the original
ship, using blueprints provided by the original
builder, but what happened to it after the
movie was filmed?
A - The cast and crew bought it between themselves
B - It was placed In a maritime museum in
Asia
C - It was sold as scrap metal
(Screen lights up C)
Rather unfortunately, after filming on the
Titanic movie had wrapped, the remains of
the full-size set were sold off as scrap metal.
Taken
Liam Neeson has made the role of Bryan Mills
a fairly iconic one in the Taken series of
movies, but he wasn't the first choice for
the role in the first movie.
Which veteran actor was originally cast as
the former CIA agent?
A - Kurt Russell
B - Jeff Bridges
C - Michael Biehn
(Screen lights up B)
The Big Lebowski star Jeff Bridges was first
cast as Bryan Mills in Taken but, after he
dropped out of the project, Liam Neeson accepted
the part, citing how he wanted to play a more
physically demanding role than the ones he
was used to.
Doctor Strange
Doctor Strange will star British actor Benedict
Cumberbatch in the titular role.
He is probably most well-known for playing
Sherlock Holmes in the BBC series Sherlock,
but how many other Holmes actors have appeared
in live action adaptations based on Marvel
properties?
A - 3
B – 4
C - 5
(Screen lights up B)
Four actors who have previously played Sherlock
Holmes on screen have gone on to appear in
live action Marvel productions.
Christopher Lee, Jeremy Brett, Robert Downey,
Jr. and Ian McKellen have appeared in Captain
America II: Death Too Soon, an episode of
The Incredible Hulk, the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and the X-Men movie franchise respectively.
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story represents the
second Hollywood collaboration between director
Gareth Edwards and composer Alexandre Desplat.
But which movie did they work on together
first?
A - Hiroshima
B - Monsters
C - Godzilla
(Screen lights up C)
It was actually the reboot of Godzilla back
in 2014 that was last both directed by Gareth
Edwards and composed by Alexandre Desplat.
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
The movie version of J.K.
Rowling's Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find
Them will use a case from real world history
to emphasise why magic users in the movie
are scared to make themselves known to the
rest of the world.
Which case will that be?
A - The Salem Witch Trials
B - The Witches of Belvoir Case
C - The Pappenheimer Family Case
(Screen lights up A)
The most famous case of real world people
being punished for alleged witchcraft - the
Salem Witch Trials - will be heavily referred
to in Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them.
They will be cited as the reason that magic
users are worried about revealing themselves.
The Incredible Hulk
In 2008's The Incredible Hulk, William Hurt's
General Ross relentlessly pursued the titular
character, but which other fictional character
did Hurt base his performance on?
A - Captain Ahab
B - Harry Callahan
C - Sir Guy of Gisbourne
(Screen lights up A)
William Hurt claimed that he based his performance
as General Ross on Captain Ahab, the obsessive
captain who relentlessly chased the titular
whale in the classic Moby Dick story.
Halloween
For years after John Carpenter's horror classic
Halloween was released, people would tell
the director how horrified they were by Michael
Myers' horribly disfigured face when his mask
was briefly removed in the movie.
Why was this a little strange?
A - He had his back to the camera at the time
B - He covered his face before it was even
revealed
C - It was the normal face of actor Tony Moran
(Screen lights up C)
All those people saw was the ordinary face
of the actor Tony Moran.
It was perfectly normal, except for a small
knife wound inflicted by Laurie during their
struggle in the closet, which was created
using special effects makeup.
Carpenter cites the power of suggestion of
cinema as the reason for their horror.
Troy
For their epic duel in 2004's Troy, Brad Pitt
and Eric Bana didn't use stunt doubles.
Instead, they made a gentlemen's agreement
to pay for every accidental hit - $50 for
each light blow and $100 for each hard blow.
How much did they end up paying each other?
A - Pitt paid Bana $750, Bana didn't owe Pitt
anything
B - Pitt paid Bana $50, Bana paid Pitt $900.
C - They each other each other $150.
(Screen lights up A)
Brad Pitt was obviously the most careless
of the two stars, as he ended up paying Eric
Bana $750, while Bana didn't owe Pitt anything
at all.
Jaws
It's a fairly well known fact that the shark
in Steven Spielberg's terrifying classic Jaws
was nicknamed "Bruce" and subsequently referred
to as such on set, but who did Spielberg name
the shark after?
A - His childhood bully
B - His intimidating uncle
C - His lawyer
(Screen lights up C)
It is actually Steven Spielberg's lawyer - a
man named Bruce Ramer - who holds the distinction
of having one of the most iconic movie monsters
in history named after him.
Thanks for watching and for taking part in
our latest behind the scenes movie facts quiz.
Did you enjoy this video?
How well did you do with the questions?
Leave your score in the comment section below
and don’t forget to subscribe to our channel
for more fun videos like this one!